Speaker 1: The Trump versus DeSantis elements
of the primary are getting ugly, even though
Ron DeSantis still hasn't even announced that he
is running a pro, DeSantis PAC has released an ad
which ran for the first time on Fox News yesterday
directly attacking Donald Trump. Now, remember,
Trump has spent a bunch of time attacking
DeSantis as well, and you could say that's
just as silly or pathetic. Trump's going
after a guy who hasn't even said that he's
actually running and I'm with you. But here is
a pro DeSantis PAC going after Trump already,
and DeSantis hasn't announced that he's running
for president. This is fascinating. Take a look.
Speaker 4: At Donald Trump is being attacked
by a Democrat prosecutor in New York. So why
is he spending millions attacking the Republican
governor of Florida? Trump stealing pages from
the Biden Pelosi playbook, repeating lies about
Social Security? Here's the truth from Governor
Ron DeSantis. You know, we're not going to
mess with Social Security as. What'd Trump
say? Entitlements. Everybody on your.
Speaker 5: Plane. At some point
they will be We will take a look at that.
Speaker 4: Trump should fight. Democrats Lie about
Governor DeSantis. What happened to Donald Trump?
Everybody is responsible for the content of it.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay. So I have to tell
you, the the ad itself is pretty lame from
a factual standpoint. Like the big thing
that they're insisting on talking about is
cuts to Social Security. And the way
that it's going is is as follows.
All of these Republicans likely at some point
played coy with whether reforming by which they
might mean cutting Social Security and Medicare
is on the table. The ad accurately points out
that Trump at one point said, Well, I think
that's something that we're going to look at.
Trump has alleged that DeSantis tried to cut it.
DeSantis voted in favor of a plan to reform, which
might have included raising the Social Security
age, retirement age. But it was nonbinding.
It's sort of like the factual story is very weak.
They're all exaggerating about each other's desire
to cut Social Security, although I have no doubt
at all that if it was politically advantageous,
they would do it. What's important about this is
the fact that the attacks themselves are a major
part of what's going on right now. The uglier the
primary, the worse it is for Republicans and for
whoever is the eventual nominee. You will see
some people argue that a spirited primary is a
good thing for Republicans. And often they will
argue when you have a tough primary. It's a test
of the candidate's strength and resilience and
their ability to appeal to different segments
of the Republican electorate. And the winner
is going to come out battle tested. That's the
argument that they make. I've not seen evidence
of that. What I have seen evidence of is that the
type of Republican Party that exists today is a
resentful grudge holding Republican Party with a
particularly uninformed electorate who often only
cares about one candidate. They don't really care
about the Republican Party. And so what we've
seen is that the more divisive, the primary,
it can lead to these irreparable fractures
and factions within the Republican Party,
supporters of different candidates who become
disillusioned, disillusioned when their candidate
loses, and they may not even end up voting in
the general election. So I think in 2023, 2024.
This ugly Republican primary is potentially
going to turn Republican voters off altogether
through the negativity and the mudslinging
and the fractured nature of the party. If
these Republicans truly believe that an ugly
primary is good for them, well, it looks like
they're going to get one. And we'll be able
to figure out over the next 18 months or so,
is this actually a good thing for the
eventual Republican nominee? I believe
the answer is no. If you think this is good
for the Republican Party, an ugly primary,
let me know. And we'll have the ad on our
YouTube channel as well as on Instagram,
as well as on the Spanish YouTube channel.
David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.